breaking news the EU has lowered the
allowed limits on chemical sunscreens
that means the sunscreen you've been
using is killing you your family your
unborn grandkids the creepy little worms
on your unborn grandkids eyelashes throw
out your toxic chemical sludge burn them
in the fire
and by some 100 safe and natural
sunscreen from my online store or don't
and watch this video first hi I'm
Michelle chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and massive sunscreen nerd there's been
a lot of fear-mongering about chemical
sunscreens there were scary sounding new
stories sunscreens absorbing into blood
killing coral reefs zinc oxide being
toxic Benzene and sunscreens I've
covered most of these before and they're
largely just the media taking things out
of context and sensationalizing them
this is partly for views because a lot
of the media do survive of AD revenue
and affiliate income now
today's topic the EU has been reviewing
the safety of sunscreens and they've
lowered some of the allowed limits of
specific ingredients for example
oxybenzone was allowed in sunscreen at a
maximum of six percent but they've now
said the use of benzophenone3 oxybenzone
at six percent in body products is not
safe for the consumer they now recommend
a maximum of 2.2 percent in body
products so some people including
scientists from other fields saw this
and started making really bold
statements about how U.S sunscreens with
six percent are unsafe and telling
people who are a bit more familiar with
this area to log off because they've
taken this one sentence very literally
to be fair if you did only read this
sentence it does sound a bit scary so
let's dive into why you probably don't
need to freak out and what you might
want to do based on this info a
disclaimer this is all going to be very
simplified I am not a toxicologist but
some toxicologists did help me out with
this script in most of the world
sunscreens are cosmetics and not drugs
and this is the case in the EU there are
less strict rules about cosmetics and
drugs but the UV filtering ingredients
that help sunscreens screen out the sun
are still in a special category the
safety gets checked a lot more than
other ingredients and you can't use them
in sunscreens until they've been added
to this special list this also tells you
the rules for using them including the
maximum percentages when it comes to
sunscreens and beauty products in
general people are always comparing the
EU and the us and one of the biggest
differences is the sunscreen ingredients
but the situation is actually kind of
the opposite of what you tend to hear
the EU allows a whole bunch more
sunscreen ingredients than the US the US
list hasn't changed since 1999 when
avobenzone was added they only have
about seven commonly used chemical
sunscreen ingredients the EU had about
20 common ones including all seven from
the US for these the two regions had
similar maximum percentages until 2 2021
when the EU started shaking things up
one thing I love about the EU is that
they show their working and it's
relatively easy to follow it's in these
secs opinions these opinions sound a bit
more hand wavy than they actually are
they are scientific opinions based on
interpreting evidence according to
almost 200 pages of guidelines but that
word opinion is important we'll come
back to that later they're written by
the scientific committee for Consumer
safety or the sccs they focus on
checking the safety of consumer products
these self-explanatory names are putting
me out of a job they look at sunscreen
and other personal care products but
also household products like detergents
toys and clothes and services like
tanning and tattooing their members are
mostly toxicologists who specialize in
risk assessment there's also chemists
Pharmacists and dermatologists they're
very impressive CVS and conflicts of
interest are all publicly available if
you want to do a bit of stalking every
once in a while if there's important new
data or someone's invented a new
sunscreen ingredient the European
commission gets the secs to look at
potential risks and write an opinion
these opinions include recommendations
for using the ingredients so below us
that percentage or only in certain
products they might even recommend
Banning an ingredient altogether
lawmakers will look at these
recommendations and most of the time put
them in the Cosmetics regulation that EU
products have to follow in late 2018 the
European commission decided to take a
closer look at potential endocrine
disruptors this included some sunscreen
ingredients which is how this opinion
came about the use of bp3 up to six
percent is not safe for the consumer but
2.2 percent is safe let's take a closer
look at the word safe first off the
phrase not safe as used by toxicologists
in a safety assessment doesn't mean the
same as what we would consider not safe
in everyday life scientists use words in
weird ways it's just part of who we are
I'm sorry and this can lead to a lot of
confusion one example is the word
significant in science it's to do with
how convincing the data is so if I'm
significantly late in a scientific study
I might be very consistently 10 seconds
late but in everyday life significant is
about how important something is so if
my friend says I'm significantly late
I'm probably half an hour late and
they're really pissed at me with the
idea of safe in everyday life we usually
think of things as either safe or
harmful if something is safe it's not
going to hurt you if something is not
safe then there's a good chance that it
will hurt you so this statement from the
report kind of sounds like 2.2 percent
oxybanzone sunscreen is fine but if you
use 2.3 percent then you're going to pee
blood or grow a third arm the worms in
your eyelashes are going to make
unsustainable farming choices but if
there's good evidence that terrible
things happen at 2.3 percent it would be
super fill in level irresponsible to let
people use 2.2 percent what if someone
uses a bit more sunscreen than they
should what if you scrape your skin and
extra sunscreen gets in what if some
water in that sunscreen evaporates and
that 2.2 gets a bit more concentrated
what if it turns out that one of the
pieces of data they use for that 2.2
percent wasn't quite right what if a new
study comes out so there is a big buffer
put in when setting these safe
percentages we can think of it more as a
spectrum there's a region where
scientists can confidently agree that
something would not be harmful based on
current info there's also a region where
scientists can confidently agree that
something would be harmful based on
current info but there's also this big
gray area in between because in reality
there's always some level of uncertainty
and variation people can use products
differently respond to ingredients in
different ways studies don't always
translate easily to actual human use new
data can come out so so not safe in the
safety assessment doesn't necessarily
mean harmful it means further into that
Gray Zone than the EU has decided that
they're comfortable with this is one of
those places where that opinion part
comes in different regions have
different approaches to working out
their limits but how far is that current
US previous EU limit of 6.6 along the
Spectrum to find out we can read the
rest of the sccs report if you watched
my video on clean Beauty how safe or
dangerous something is the risk depends
on both Hazard and exposure a hazard is
something that's potentially harmful
like a lion or even a rabbit you could
trip over it it could convince you to do
a whole bunch of messed up stuff but
even a lion isn't always going to be
harmful if it's very far away in a cage
we have practically no exposure to it so
even though it is hazardous it has that
potential the actual risk of harm to us
is very low if our exposure is is high
we're in the cage with the lion then the
wrist changes and becomes very high even
though it's the same lion this concept
is sometimes referred to as the dose
makes the poison so for a safety
assessment of a cosmetic ingredient the
sccs will look at both exposure and
Hazard to work out the overall risk they
put that line into context for exposure
the sccs worked out how much oxybenzone
95 of consumers would be reasonably
exposed to so they try to capture normal
use if you're eating sunscreen on toast
every morning it's not going to be as
relevant for you for most ingredients in
beauty products the main way that we're
exposed is by absorbing it through skin
sometimes there are other ways that it
gets into your body like breathing in a
spray or eating some lip balm here are
some of the factors that they take into
account most of these are probably
things you expect if you have an
ingredient that absorbs easily through
skin you'll have a high exposure it's
also high if it's a leave-on product if
it's used in products at high
percentages if it's in a product that
gets used in large amounts or very
frequently I want to highlight this bit
aggregate exposure this is if the
ingredient turns up in more than one of
the products that you use every time I
post about toxicologists during safety
assessments someone will ask if it's in
more than one product couldn't it add up
yes it could and toxicologists do take
this into account for the oxybenzone
calculation they use 9.9 as the fraction
of the total applied that would be
absorbed into blood they estimated this
from a study using skin samples but they
weren't quite satisfied with the
methodology so they took the average
absorption which was 3.1 percent and
added two standard deviations to it to
get 9.9 percent so the number that
they're using is more than three times
the actual measured average from the
study most people would probably absorb
a lot less so you can see how they're
quite conservative with their estimates
whenever there's uncertainty they
usually will add extra buffer to work
out how much oxybenzone was put on the
skin in the first place they used the
average sunscreen application amounts
from a couple of studies which was 18
grams of body sunscreen now some of you
are probably typing in the comments I
apply much more than 18 grams on my body
that's what the guidelines say I could
be using a dangerous amount because I'm
following the guidelines
this will make sense in a bit so from
this info they calculate an SED the
systemic exposure dose which means how
much of the ingredient you would be
exposed to in a whole body sense they
did this for an average 60 kilo person
using these average amounts of a
sunscreen with the maximum six percent
oxybenzone so for example for body
sunscreens they calculated the SED to be
1.8 milligrams of oxybenzone per kilo
body weight per day so that's exposure
the secs assessments also look at the
hazard first they go through all of the
relevant data about the ingredient and
how it could potentially be harmful this
includes things like skin irritation
allergies cancer fertility problems
damage to DNA endocrine disruption they
look at tests on cells tissues animals
and information from computer models
they also look at human data for
oxybenzone there are some examples of
clinical studies and volunteers like FDA
studies from those sunscreens absorb
into blood headlines on top of this they
look for example samples of people
actually being harmed by that ingredient
and if there's population level data
that's been analyzed to find links they
also look at information on similar
ingredients that could be extrapolated
based on all of this they pick a dose
that they expect to cause little to no
harm for most cosmetic ingredients they
use something called the no observed
adverse effect level or the no Al this
is the highest amount of the ingredient
that didn't cause a harmful effect in
studies now none of the chemical
sunscreens commonly used in the EU or
the US have been recorded to cause harm
in humans outside of things like
allergic reactions and irritation which
can happen with pretty much any skin
care ingredient but that's not what we
care about we want to know about the
longer term health effects that
organizations like the ewg keep claiming
our products are causing cancer
endocrine disruption birth defects I'm
kind of joking but at the same time
these are the health effects that freak
us all out the most so for chemical
sunscreens there isn't a lot of human
data this is a good thing because it is
real world evidence that there's been no
clear serious health effects in all the
millions of people using oxybenzone
since it was launched in the 1970s but
at the same time for the purposes of a
safety assessment it's less good it
means you either have to a feed
oxybenzone to people until something bad
happens and scientists aren't allowed to
do this anymore except in movies or B
you have to translate information from
less relevant studies mostly animal
studies animals are similar to humans in
many ways but they aren't the same so
scientists have to try to convert what
happens in an animal to what happens in
a human and how accurate this
translation is can vary a lot depending
on the ingredient and the animal
chocolate and rat poison are both toxic
to dogs but I'm not going to stop eating
chocolate and I'm definitely not going
to start eating rat poison so this
approximation adds another layer of
uncertainty and this is is another place
where that scientific opinion comes in
there can be different approaches to
interpreting each piece of data with
different pros and cons and a lot of the
time more than one approach is
considered scientifically legitimate so
for oxybenzone the secs picked 14
endpoints from mouse and rat studies 14
harmful effects that could be relevant
to humans then out of these they pick
the one with the lowest no Al this was
from a study on pregnant rats being fed
oxybenzone in this study when the rats
were fed a lot of oxybenzone they saw a
whole bunch of stuff happen to the rats
including significantly reduced AGG
which is the distance between the Peach
Pit and the cherries some scientists had
to use a microscope to measure this
which I think is a pretty good setup for
a joke
when rats were fed less but still quite
a lot they only saw one potentially bad
effect less sperm producing cells in
male rat fetuses so the sccs picked one
dose lower from the study for the Noel
okay so now that we have these two
numbers the lowest safe exposure level
from relevant animal studies and the
actual exposure that consumers get we're
ready to do the margin of safety
calculation basically how much are we
getting with normal sunscreen use
compared to their safe amount the first
row of this table shows that the margin
of safety for a body sunscreen is 38 so
in other words if a 60 kilo person
applied 18 grams of 6.6 oxybenzone
sunscreen to their whole body and absorb
about one tenth of it they would be
expected to get 1 38th of the safe
amount but the secs wants a margin of
safety of 100 to take into account
uncertainty things like converting
between rats and humans if some people
react worse than others incomplete data
they want the average person to only get
one percent of that safe amount so
that's why they dropped the percentage
allowed from six percent to 2.2 percent
that's how much would give a 60 kilo
some 1 100th of that Noel if you wanted
to actually hit that no Al you would
have to use a hundred times the average
amount which I don't think even
sunscreen nodes do or the average person
would have to use sunscreen with 220
oxybenzo now keep in mind that on top of
this margin of safety of 100 there are a
lot of other safety buffers for example
the effect that they care about is a
drop in sperm cells in a male rat fetus
developing fetuses are a lot more
sensitive than children or adults the
vast majority of people using sunscreen
aren't pregnant the amount that actually
caused the bad effect in the study was
three times higher than the safe amount
that they use for the calculation and as
I mentioned earlier the average amount
actually absorbed in the skin absorption
study was three times lower than what
they used in the calculation so if
you're wondering how much you'd need to
use to actually have the smallest
harmful effect based on the same data
and assumptions the sunscreen would have
to have about two thousand percent
oxybenzone and that's for a harmful
effect on a male fetus assuming it's the
same for humans and rats it's also worth
mentioning that the scientists who did
the rat study didn't think that the
sperm cell effect was that important the
safe level that they indicated they
would have picked was about 10 times
higher now I'm not saying that I
disagree with the secs they're deciding
what a good policy is for a population
including people who are pregnant with a
male fetus although probably not a male
rat fetus and if you're deciding for a
population with millions of people then
a tiny decrease in health risk can make
some difference on top of that there are
tons of other sunscreen ingredients
available in the EU most European
sunscreens don't even use oxybenzone
anymore so it isn't like sun safety will
be massively impacted by this change but
at the same time you can see how
cautious they're being there's the
massive margin of safety the buffers
that they add whenever there's
uncertainty on top of that the new limit
comes from new data from an animal study
there's no evidence that six percent or
six hundred percent would actually be
harmful to humans so not safe according
to an EU safety assessment really
doesn't mean that you should Panic if
you've been using six percent oxybenzone
sunscreen the whole time even though the
EU is known for being really
conservative when it comes to safety it
still isn't like the EU Regulators have
gone around knocking six percent
oxybenzone sunscreens out of people's
hands and they haven't made any
announcements telling people to throw
out their sunscreens this report was
published in March 2021 the limits came
into place July 2022 then companies have
another 12 months to stop selling the
products that are over the limit that is
two and a bit years between the finding
of not safe for the consumer and no
longer having the products available so
this really highlights that not safe and
harmful to your health are very
different so that's the story for body
products why is the limit different for
face products as you might have guessed
from this whole explanation you you
apply a lot less of a face product on a
smaller area of skin the sccs found a
margin of safety of 447 for a face cream
with six percent oxybenzone so that was
confirmed to be safe this was for an
application amount of about a quarter
teaspoon so you could apply that four
times a day and still stay under that
one percent margin of safety let's take
a quick look at the sccs safety
assessments for the other sunscreen
ingredients after krylene was confirmed
as safe at up to 10 for humans the
exception was with sprays when used in
combination with other products taking
into account that aggregate exposure
then it would have a margin of safety of
92 so the limit was lowered to nine
percent to get it back to a margin of a
hundred homothalate was found to be not
safe at 10 percent the limit was lowered
to 0.5 percent for body products and
7.34 for face products this is actually
a bit of a problem for body sunscreens
homicide is good at keeping other
sunscreen ingredients dissolved so
there's going to be a lot of
reformulating for both of these the secs
found that there wasn't enough evidence
to say that endocrine disruptors for
4mbc the secs said there was enough
evidence that it may act as an endocrine
disruptor and has effects on both the
thyroid and estrogen systems there
wasn't enough data to work out what the
new limit should be but they did say it
would be lower than the current limit of
four percent octanoxate and titanium
dioxide will also be reassessed soon so
what should you do if you're a more
cautious person you might be wondering
if you should switch to sunscreens that
follow these new limits or even avoid
these ingredients completely just in
case I can't give you personal advice
everyone's risk calculus is different
it's really a conversation you should be
having with your doctor but generally
speaking there are some useful takeaways
from these safety assessments that are
worth considering when working out your
personal pros and cons exposure and dose
how much sunscreen you use and how often
is important the SEC has assessment got
to their limit based on using 18 grams a
day but you might be applying a lot more
or a lot less for example I only apply
full body sunscreen a few days a year
when I go to the beach but someone who
works outdoors might be applying and
reapplying several times a day most days
vulnerability is also important I'm not
talking about sharing your childhood
trauma to do well in a reality TV show
it's whether the risks of a particular
sunscreen ingredient are especially
relevant for you the most common concern
is probably pregnancy a developing fetus
is more strongly affected by all sorts
of things alcohol aspirin chamomitches
as we saw these safety assessments do
look at what happens to developing
fetuses and a lot of limits are set
based on that but if you're pregnant you
would have more reason to consider
temporarily lowering your exposure to
risks even if Just For Peace of Mind the
other side of the equation is also
important what are the costs of not
using that sunscreen ingredient you
might consider things like a family
history of skin cancel how much UV
exposure you get and whether or not you
have access to suitable alternatives are
other sunscreens available where you are
and within your budget will stretching
your budget make you under reply is
protective clothing appropriate for
whatever you're doing I've talked about
hats umbrellas and UV protective
clothing before I think it's also worth
noting that safe limits for cosmetic
ingredients will be constantly changing
based on new data or new regulations or
new procedures for working out safety
there is always going to be some
uncertainty and I know that at a gut
level that does feel uncomfortable we
humans haven't really evolved to be okay
with uncertainty when it comes to
potentially harmful things but it's
worth remembering that everything is
potentially harmful we just don't
necessarily think of them that way
because we don't see announcements about
new risk assessments and these
adjustments are actually a good sign
that the system is working the way it
should rather than a sign that something
has gone wrong the vast majority of the
time these changes have happen because
of new data from models and experiments
not because people have gotten hurt from
using products with these ingredients
it's a nice reminder that there is
research happening there are experts
putting the new Research into context
against all of the other evidence and
updating the guidelines regularly to
make the products that are already
pretty darn safe even safer I hope this
video was useful thank you to everyone
who helped me with the script most Skin
lab is also on YouTube check him out if
you want more from me hit the Subscribe
and the notification Bell I'm on
Instagram Tick Tock and my blog as well
more videos are popping up around me